estás graficando el polígono abc de en
el plano de coordenadas la longitud del
segmento ave debe ser igual a la del
segmento de ce y ambos segmentos son
horizontales los siguientes son tres de
los vértices del polígono a que es el 11
sé que es el 4.5 4 y de que es el menos
1.5 4 cuáles son las coordenadas del
punto vemos si debe estar en el
cuadrante 1 bueno pues vamos a dibujar
estos puntos que nos dan el punto a que
voy a poner en color naranja debe estar
en el 1,1 es decir debe estar aquí uno a
la derecha y uno hacia arriba este punto
de acá es el punto a muy bien el punto c
que es el 4.5 4 y que voy a pintar en
azul en color azul debe estar como por
acá debe estar 4.5 a la derecha como por
aquí y 4 unidades hacia arriba
cuatro unidades hacia arriba más o menos
por acá entonces este sería el punto c
el punto c luego el punto d es el menos
1.5 4 s le voy a pintar color rosa y
tenemos que ir 1.5 a la izquierda porque
es menos 1.5 y tenemos que subir 4
tenemos que subir 4 entonces más o menos
que quedaría como por acá este de aquí
sería el punto de d y en efecto parece
ser que el segmento de s es horizontal
de hecho es horizontal porque ambos
puntos tienen la misma coordenada en 4 y
4 entonces déjame trazar este segmento
no sé en color azul en el color pues en
color morado mejor entonces nos quedaría
algo de este estilo que en efecto es
horizontal y lo que nosotros queremos
hacer es encontrar dónde está el punto b
cuáles son sus coordenadas nos dan más
información nos dicen que la longitud
del segmento ave debe ser igual a del
segmento ala del segmento de c o bien
cede y es así la podemos calcular por
qué
justo conocemos cuáles son las
coordenadas de estos dos puntos para ir
desde hace es lo mismo que ver pues
cuánto es de ir de menos 1.5 a 4.5 de
menos 1.5 a 0 es 1.5 lo voy a apuntar
por acá 1.5 y luego tenemos que ir de 0
a 4.5 ahí le voy a sumar 4.5 entonces la
longitud de este segmento es esta suma
que es igual a 6 que voy a apuntarlo por
acá hay otra forma de verlo que es con
las coordenadas que aquí ponemos las
coordenadas de de que es menos 1.5 coma
4 y acá las de c que es 4.54 4.54
podemos encontrar la longitud de este
segmento viendo cuando recorrimos
haciendo la diferencia de las
coordenadas en x tomamos la coordenada
final que es 4.5
punto 5 y a esa le restamos la
coordenada inicial todo es en las
coordenadas x porque es lo único que
cambia porque es un segmento horizontal
entonces hay que restarle menos 1.5 y
eso por supuesto nos vuelve a dar 6 le
voy a poner aquí 6 sale bueno entonces
con esto ya tenemos la longitud del
segmento cde ya nada más tenemos que
encontrar un punto b que también tenga
esa longitud que haga que ave que ave
tenga y tenga éste sea horizontal y
además que me quede en este cuadrante
bueno déjame primero trazar y todavía
seguir trazando algunos lados del
paralelo gramos éste lo podemos dibujar
ahora vamos a preguntarnos dónde puede
estar ve déjame agarrar el color verde
entonces el punto b lo vamos a ubicar en
color verde dice que ave tiene que ser
horizontal ave tiene que ser horizontal
entonces ve debe estar en algún lugar de
esta línea verdad debe estar por ahí
quien saben dónde pero debe estar en esa
línea para que tenga
a coordenada en que el segmento ave sea
horizontal pero además sabemos que que
la longitud de ave tiene que ser 6
entonces ve puede estar por acá más o
menos o por acá pero no puede estar por
acá porque queremos que esté en el
primer cuadrante y los cuadrantes pues
esté acá es el primero
estoy acá este el segundo esté acá es el
tercero y este de acá es el cuarto
entonces el punto b debe estar como por
acá déjame marcarlo como por acá sale
pero no sabes que antes de marcar lo
vamos a encontrar sus coordenadas cómo
le hacemos pues bueno nos tomamos el
punto a sabemos que sus coordenadas son
11 y entonces el punto b debe de tener
la misma altura su segunda coordenada es
es algo como 1 verdad su segunda
coordenada la coordenada iniesta 1 y la
primera coordenada la encontramos
sumando estas seis unidades a la
coordenada en x d
sale eso justo hace que ave me da vida 6
entonces si estoy aquí es 1 hay que
sumar 6 y llegamos a 7 de modo que el
punto b está como por acá el punto b
está como por acá y sus coordenadas son
7,1 déjame acabar de dibujar el
paralelogramo porque queda un
paralelogramo verdad algo de este estilo
y entonces así le hacemos así ubicamos
las coordenadas del punto b logramos que
el punto b quedar en el primer cuadrante
que ave fuera horizontal y que la
distancia de ave fuera igual que la
distancia de c a d